hey everybody how's it be how does it go
silver right here again with another
parka text video today I'm going to play
sheer cliffs which is not a scenario
that I made but it's a scenario that I
really like because it's very similar to
a rollercoaster tycoon in one scenario
that some people might know and it's
just really fun this scenario is well at
least was one of my favorites when I
kind of play tested it a bit before the
scenario pack came out so let's see what
this thing is actually like the
description says that these ancient
cliffs were once a popular tourist
destination but now like dormant work
some amusement park charm into this
small space and bring back the crowds
now if you look at the goals of this
they're not too intense we just need to
have 500 people in the park but once you
actually see the full extents of this
map you're gonna see why this is such a
challenge and why this is not nearly as
easy as it seems because this map right
here is super limited at least we have
one goal completed which is to have no
loan debts but I'm probably gonna
uncomplete that go at some point in this
playthrough but yeah we just have very
little available space just a little bit
of flatland above here and then some
space at the bottom of this cliff to
work with this well we could also extend
over here so clearly the main challenge
here is that the terrain is really
difficult to work with and really
limited and I'm already wondering
whether I actually want to build a path
down here or whether I just want to keep
everything much more simple but I think
I'm gonna have to do that somehow I
think I'm somehow gonna have to work
some sort of path down these cliffs and
make sure I can actually build some
normal flat rides and stuff like that
down here as well but the main reason
why I like this scenario so much I think
it's just that it's so much fun to try
and come up with coaster layouts that
make use of this really unique geography
in general for me personally having
unique kinds of geographies and the
settings to build your own stuff in is
one of my favorite things about playing
scenarios that even if you know it's not
all about gameplay you sometimes have
these really creative building elements
that you can only get in scenario
and you don't really get in playing
sandbox and this is just one of them
sometimes you get these really
interesting limitations that force you
to be a bit more creative in how you're
building and these kinds of geographical
challenges are just kind of my thing now
I'm actually not really sure what we
start out with here but yeah god that is
limited
oof so I think my first priority is
actually gonna be to start researching
coasters because I'm not gonna be okay
with just this choice of right now I
guess the thrill rides are also not too
good but I just really don't like the
junior coaster in the world mouse I'm
gonna start with that and then we'll see
I don't have too much scenery so I think
I'm gonna keep that very simple
we'll see how what else I can actually
add to this map so without further ado
let's get into it all right now you
already know that your boy is not gonna
be satisfied with a kiddie coaster or
some stupid wild mouse coaster so I
wrote the dice on the research
department and they came up with an RMC
Raptor which is absolutely amazing
I love this coaster type not just
because it's really fun to build and it
seems like a really cool ride in real
life as well for anybody who hasn't
checked it out yet I highly recommend
checking out a POV of Wonder Woman lasso
of truth or real Blaser that's to Six
Flags parks I've forgotten exactly which
ones but there are super cool coasters
of this type that give a really cool
example of what you can do with this but
yeah it's not only a really cool coaster
type realistically I think but in terms
of gameplay it's just so nice because
you can build it really compact and it's
just kind of fun to build it just looks
nice I don't know it's it's aesthetic
there's something about the look of this
track that just makes it really easy to
fit into different kinds of spaces I'd
say the only downside to it of course is
that the the throughput is absolutely
horrible because you can only fit about
eight people on a train I think at max
maybe you can make them a bit longer but
it's not you know double seating as most
roller coasters are it's just a single
line of trains with one person per car
so it's highly inefficient but it's
still a good coaster that I think
especially at the
start if the scenario works out really
well because even though the throughput
isn't the very best you can still get a
decent efficiency if you add a
mid-course brake run and a brake run at
the end of the right so you can have
three trains on it and as long as you
just fit in enough inversions and
thrilling elements you can even ask a
quite terrible price for these things
like usually I think I raise the price
to twelve dollars or so which given the
actual amount of money that it takes to
build these things because they are also
relatively cheap it's pretty good so
altogether pretty cool coaster and I'm
really glad I started out the scenario
with this
the very idea for this layout was just
to start the station at the top of the
cliff and just use up all of that
momentum to make your way through the
layout have a mid-course brake run in
the middle of the layouts just to slow
it down a little bit the general area
around the mid-course brake run I'd say
is very heavily inspired by the layout
of Rio Blazer which also has that same
kind of turnaround elements except
without a brake run and yeah just make
your way back to the station with a lift
hill at the end of the ride which also
makes it really efficient because
usually lifts hills is kind of where the
capacity of your coasters tend to either
be limited or where you tend to run into
issues where the coaster has to wait on
top of the lift hill for the next train
to clear the block and you don't have
either of these issues just rolling out
of the station and once you get back to
the ride you only need a very small
amount of lift hill you know get back up
to the station height it's just really
efficient to have a station at the top
of the layouts I guess the only thing is
that in a real life situation I'm not a
huge fan of having a station somewhere
near the top of the layout because it
means that you have the most boring part
of the ride at the end of the ride as
well
I remember for instance ninja in Six
Flags Magic Mountain is built like this
where you start off with a very small
lift hill from the station you go
through the entire layout which is
really fun it's such a cool coaster but
then at the end of it you have the slow
boring lift whole back into the station
so I do kind of prefer to have a
at the start of a layout so it builds up
the anticipation and you don't have this
boring anti-climactic ending to a
coaster but from a gameplay perspective
I think it works out really well and
besides a drop out of the station is
always really cool there are very few
coasters in the world which have a
station at a higher altitude than the
rest of their layout and have some kind
of drop out of the station I think the
best one that I've personally been in
was probably helix in Liseberg
which drops out of the station at quite
a steep angle as well like if you sit at
the back of the car you just get some
air time as you whip out of the station
which is absolutely amazing such a cool
element so yeah this is for me at least
these are the kind of things that make
building coasters in an interesting
geographical location like this cliff so
interesting because you can play with
these layout elements that you normally
don't see unless the coaster is based in
some kind of unique geography now with
the coaster I'm sort of suspending the
station above the cliff which makes it
possible to drop straight out of the
station but not waste too much a
valuable land space because you do see
that you know the amount of actual flat
land that I have on top of these cliffs
is very limited so I wanted to suspend
the station off of that so I can have a
wide path and not make this whole park
seem too crammed and then I ended up
doing the same with this flat ride here
just because I think it looks really
cool I think in real life this is a
probably a no-go because flat rides need
some kind of foundations and supporting
that probably wouldn't work like this I
I really wouldn't see the point of
suspending any kind of ride off the edge
of a cliff even with real life rides
that sort of are built on cliffs they'll
always be built on the cliff and then
have the actual ride sort of extend over
it I think a good example is probably
the stratosphere tower in Las Vegas
where there are flat rides on top of a
giant Tower but then the actual
foundation structures are still very
firmly nudged in the middle of the tower
and not sort of overhanging it but yeah
I I thought it would just look good one
bike text so I'm going
that's there's also a small path leading
down the cliffs because I do want to
expand the park bit down there I don't
think it would be doable to build this
whole park on top of the cliff and
beside I just really like the idea of
having this winding pathway that
narrowly climbs up and down the cliff
I'm not sure how much the guests are
going to like it because I think they're
probably gonna get very tired once they
have to climb up this thing but it looks
cool so I'm going with it now the rest
of this park I actually kind of wants a
theme almost as if it were a beachside
resort which is a bit strange
I guess because in this this context the
the beachside apartments and hotels and
beach houses and things like this that
you would normally see at a beach resort
are perched on top of the rocks instead
of actually being at the beach but I
just think it looks really cool it's the
most fitting theme that I could really
come up with that fits the beach theme
and also works with the entrance
building because the entrance building
is something that I can't help but keep
because you can't remove it so I want to
try and fit all of the other buildings
as much into that style as possible
while also having as much variation in
the types of buildings as well so I
figured within that whole the context I
think the the theme of having some sort
of beach resort works best and to
establish that theme I figured that
nothing works better than a big
apartment building which I guess here
would probably be a hotel I think this
would work quite well as a small kind of
themed hotel building kind of modern
architecture much more new than the
other buildings but you know at this
size you can't just make a building that
looks like a tiki hut and it's built out
of logs and thatched roofs so I think it
works like this it's also probably the
best place to put this building because
it's right in front of a section of the
cliff where there's no building in front
of it you don't have the coaster station
or a flat ride in front of it so whoever
has to you know pay up for how extremely
expensive the rooms with those balconies
probably are they're gonna have a really
cool view of the sea as well
and next to that it's time for a food
court of some sort I figured so this is
going to be my food building very simple
there's not really going to be much to
it but it helps to cover up the area
behind these two buildings which is
going to be the backstage a kind of
section and I believe between these two
buildings I just built a very small
alleyway that allows the staff to get to
the backside now at this point I was
actually struggling because I realized
looking at my research four stalls which
I forgot to look into earlier I actually
didn't have much to work with so I had
to do some research real quick and
actually get some stalls ended up
getting burgers which is fine and whole
drinks which is absolutely the worst
thing ever because this is already a
super tropical Park but I think the
guests are not going to complain about
that so ended up just putting down the
hot drinks I actually have to correct
myself here this little building this
newest one is actually the food courts
and the other building is where I put
some other stuff actually did I even put
anything in that yeah I think I put the
vending machine there so that was sort
of my first real food court because
before I had the stalls I just had a
vending machine so people could buy cans
and chips which is kind of terrible but
at least it's some food and drinks and
then once I actually got the research I
built the new proper food markets
whatever the case we've got some rides
we've got some buildings we've got the
basic facilities in place I'm really
happy that the enterance building
already has a toilets and an information
kiosk in it that makes my job a little
bit easier and yeah next to that I
decided to just build a Top Spin because
it's just about the only right that I
could feasibly fit into a space on this
map but I think it works decently well
and even if you're in the Top Spin you
do have that view down the cliff which
is really cool
probably one of the coolest settings for
a Top Spin the only reason I decided not
to put it over the cliff and actually
have it behind the path is because I
needed some space to build the station
for this girl our Eurofighter which I'm
building right now
and I just this is another one of my
favorite Costa types you probably know
it to sing at this point that I built a
lot of Euro fighters and monorail
coasters in my scenario builds because
they're just such cool coasters they
work really well together
and yeah they're just fun to build Euro
fighters just like monorail coasters are
not the most efficient coasters when it
comes to throughput so I am gonna
feature some mid-course brake run action
on this coaster as well I'm gonna have
to very carefully see how I'm going to
distribute the trains on this thing but
all together I think it works decent in
this setting and the cool thing is also
that you don't even have to do the
vertical lift hill at the start of the
layouts I'm just dropping straight from
the cyst from the station into that
vertical drop down the cliff which is
pretty cool I would love to see a
coaster like an actual Eurofighter do
this maybe an infinity coaster or
whatever kind of coaster having a
station on top of a cliff and then just
dropping down from that is super cool
and then the rest of the layouts is just
more or less sort of standard
Eurofighter fare it's not too
interesting but as you might notice
there aren't very long stretches of
track without a break run from the first
rope you just have a vertical loop and
then over-banked turn straight into
mid-course brake run after which we just
have some turns a corkscrew and a helix
and then it's already back into the
station so it's a very simple layout
with lots of break runs actions because
even before the lift hill back into the
station there's another break run just
to make sure that I can constantly
rotate through these trains and just
have the maximum capacity that's the
same reason that I'm creating the double
station here which I think for a
Eurofighter works better than any other
kind of coaster because you really don't
need a lot of space to build a double
station for Eurofighter because these
trains are just so small theoretically
you could even do it with stations that
are one tile long but I just don't like
the look of that I don't think it really
looks realistic in real life you do find
load and unload stations for your
fighters but they're usually a bit
longer than just the length
of the Eurofighter cars so I think this
is a way to find a good balance between
realism and in-game gameplay and
efficiency and as you can see while I'm
testing this thing I'm running three
trains and the brake run at the end kind
of allows this coaster to run four
trains I think theoretically but it's
not really necessary
you've always got one train loading and
then another train unloading directly
behind that as it leaves the station so
as you can see it just keeps going and I
think it's probably about as efficient
as this thing needs to be and besides
these are actually slightly more
efficient I would say than the monorail
coaster because even though the trains
are very short they are four rows wide
so you can still fit eight people per
train so 24 people can be on this
coaster at a time and they're rotating
like every twenty or thirty seconds or
so so it's still really good through
bits like I find that it really helps to
go into the results of the coaster and
not necessarily you know check the data
of excitement intensity and that kind of
stuff even though that's also really
important but I think it's all it's
always important to note how many people
can ride the coaster per hour at max and
then see you know how much money can you
ask them to write this coaster and then
see how much profits am I going to make
off of this coaster when it's running
and it's best which it usually isn't
because every now and then it rains or
you just don't feel the entire queue but
for this Eurofighter I think it went
over one and a half thousand dollars so
that's really good so I decided to just
leave it as this
it's about as efficient as you can
reasonably make a somewhat realistic
Eurofighter layout in this game I think
and then for everything else I'm just
making this very similar actually to the
station of the monorail coaster just
with a different roof color and kind of
playing with the cue there a bit making
this kind of a green roof on top of a
wooden structure to cover the cue line I
also put a lot of trees into the the
cliff face as you might see which are
actually sakura trees they're actually
the cherry blossom trees but if you make
them green and sink them into rock work
and combine them with palm trees and
things like this I think they make for
some really good throw pickle shrubbery
so you can put you can see me putting
those trees everywhere another thing
that you might have noticed is that I'm
using those trees to get rid of supports
because if it weren't for those trees
there would be supports underneath the
station of the monorail coaster and
underneath the flat ride which is
suspended off the side of the cliff and
I didn't want to have those supports I
wanted to make my own custom ones so I
use the bunch of trees underneath it to
remove the supports so just a little tip
sometimes if you want to get rid of
supports of coasters you can put a bunch
of shrubbery underneath it and as long
as you're using trees that are sunken
into the ground to make those shrubs and
then the supports are gonna disappear
and that can be pretty handy
now my final ride for my chair is being
really loud I hope you didn't hear that
probably did my my final right of this
episode is going to be a junior coaster
which I've also built so many of so I'm
really trying my hardest to come up with
new layouts for these things as well
it's not always easy because I've kind
of done everything at this point but I
think this layout manages to do
something new and also explore this
little island which I just bought by the
way this is not something that you get
with the scenario but you can buy it for
what like ten thousand dollars or
something like that
it's not the cheapest thing but with the
monorail coaster and the Eurofighter the
money was already flowing in like crazy
so I felt pretty confident it just
infinitely spent money only whenever I
wanted to because as you can see I'm
earning like over two thousand a month
so that's more than good enough and I'm
not really going to add too much to this
island otherwise I'm gonna keep it quite
simple but I think it's it's a nice way
to finish the scenario and actually make
use of all of the land that's available
to me and not just keep everything on
top and a round of those cliffs now as
for the theme of this I actually don't
quite know what the general area of this
general build would be it's very generic
kind of tropical it could probably be
somewhere in South America but just as
well be on the tropical island somewhere
or maybe even the Mediterranean if you
could even find cliffs like this
anywhere in the Mediterranean I'm really
not sure but I think it works alright
because even in some tropical regions in
the world and South America you do find
a lot of Mediterranean influences and
architecture so this is the general
theme that I'm going for I would say and
because this is a nautical theme and we
do have the ocean here presumably I'm
just assuming that this is probably the
ocean and we just are building on some
sand banks here I wanted to build a
little lighthouse over here as well and
this is really a lighthouse lighthouse
because it's not just the Tower
I'm also attaching in the house
and just going for this generic kind of
Mediterranean stucco architecture it's
very difficult to create very specific
themes in this game because everything
is just so basic that I think it's more
about the vibe that you're getting from
any particular building as opposed to
details because even when it comes to
distinguishing between different styles
of Roman architecture or other classical
architecture or maybe even Egyptian or
things like this there isn't that much
that you can create in terms of
differences it's all just more about
general appearance and colors and how
everything comes together so yeah it's
hard to say that there's anything
particular about this build I would I
just loved the way that this looked
having this little house on the rocks
and just putting a bunch of palm trees
and ferns and bushes around it and
having a bit of interaction with the
coaster as well I think it's a lot more
interesting than just leaving this whole
area bare and then I'm also creating a
very small path leading up to the
lighthouse from the real path which of
course people aren't going to be able to
walk but I think it adds a little bit of
theming to the entire look of this
another thing that I ended up adding is
some grass patches here in there which I
think kind of resembles the the helm
grass that you find in sand dunes of
course the grass isn't really meant for
this normally I find that I really don't
use that much grass because it's just
very heavy on your CPU and it's really
tall I'm honestly fine with just leaving
all of the grass in my scenario play
throughs I completely empty but for a
case like this I think the grass patches
really pop outs and create this sort of
Center look so I it was kind of an
accident I was just wondering you know
what kind of shrubbery I could put on
the beach because I wanted to have some
ground shrubbery but of course not too
much because it is a beach after on it
it's just sand but I think this works
out really well and it's definitely
something that I want to remember for in
the future in case I ever do any more
desert scenarios or things like this
because this just works out pretty well
and then when it comes to the station of
this coaster again very similar kind of
architecture
I'm just using some of the round pillars
from the castle set which are supposed
to be stone pillars but just giving them
a wooden color makes them kind of look
like really dark wooden logs and then
using the border pieces which have those
little ends which I'm actually not sure
what they're supposed to be used for
could be for doorways or things like
this but yeah I like to use those at the
end of the pillars to make them resemble
the the fact that these logs in real
life sort of go into each other and I
don't know it's a really it's really
difficult to describe it but in real
life logs you know in this kind of
architecture don't perfectly just attach
to one another and you often see them
either roped to different logs so they
don't use nails or anything like this so
you can always have parts of logs
sticking out so using some of those
little pieces and making the pillars a
little bit higher then the horizontal
logs are really creates the same kind of
look even if we can't make these ropes
together log structures in this game
because that's just to find a level of
detail I say yeah that's basically it
for this station and then I decided to
add one more flat right over here
because I got it which is the pirate
ship which I think works out really well
with the theme and especially this parts
of the park being a bit more ocean
themed than the rest of the park is and
with just a small pier and a small
pavilion with some benches to sit down
at that is basically the scenario
finished so I didn't even do a real-time
section in the middle of this time
that's because I was just on a roll and
I just wanted to keep going and all in
all this turned out to be one of the
quickest scenarios that I've done but
really fun I really enjoy trying to work
with the interesting geographical
challenges and building some coasters on
the cliffs it's just really cool so one
of my favorite scenario is at least the
playthrough so far I'd say and let's
take a final look that's the and our
final products and see what it's like so
the goal of this scenario is to reach
500 guests and we
currently at 489 so if my math serves me
right that means we're actually only
nine people actually only seven people
until we reach the 500 I think it'll be
fine there's a this is a downward arrow
here for some reason but honestly
looking at these crowds I'm not really
sure if I believe that anyway I guess
this is probably going to be okay no
never mind we just completed the goal so
we don't actually have to wait a couple
of months until we actually reach it so
yeah that's the scenario
this was quite a short one but I had fun
let's move on to the next video now I'm
just kidding I'm gonna do a quick POV of
some of the coasters out here because I
think the layouts are pretty interesting
and it would be nice to go over some of
the scenery but to be honest this was a
pretty short and simple scenario at the
end of the day so obviously we have the
RMC raptor coaster over here which
honestly I just I can never get enough
of these things I know I've said this so
many times before but these things are
just so fun to build and they're always
much better in terms of capacity than
you would think especially if you add a
couple of mid-course brake runs and it
just looks so good I just love the way
that the track kind of flows as a ribbon
so I try to preserve that look in this
layout as well and just make it this
kind of ribbon like layout flowing next
to the the cliff sides here and
basically just after a couple of very
standard elements we go into this really
strange final inversion into the lift
Hill I just love coasters that end with
the lift Hill it's not great for a
climax but it is very satisfying to not
have to waste any kinetic energy on the
ride so after that we can move to the
Eurofighter which does basically the
same thing and actually let's just catch
it quick POV on this one and I still
like how this layout is kind of standard
fare for Eurofighter it's a bit more
sprawled out especially around this area
you can see it's kind of unusual with
the mid-course brake run as well but
otherwise it uses some very standard
elements for a Eurofighter just with the
station at the top of the layouts
at the bottom of it and again I think
the emphasis on efficiency and
throughput for both of these coasters
was pretty good because I do have quite
a queue for this one and I'm really
trying to get as much capacity from this
thing as I can but looking at it the
theoretical amount of customers per
month is 132 which is not too bad in
park texts and the max theoretical
earnings are also a thousand five
hundred something or at least that's
what it's at right now which honestly is
pretty good I'd say so finally of course
we have the junior coaster and I also
have to say I think this is my favorite
ride in the park or in general my
favorite area it's the one that feels
most coherence kind of like the most
recent expansions of the park and even
though it's very simple and only
features these two rides and I need to
probably fix up the timing on the block
brakes actually looking at this I just
like the way that it all fits together
and the color scheme - I feel like the
orange purple color scheme is a bit
underrated and underused it does feel a
little bit Nickelodeon and I guess it's
a color scheme that you can usually find
in kiddie areas of theme parks but I
think it works and it's a nice bright
color scheme then especially in a
tropical setting like this one I think
looks pretty fun I guess I can't
actually do anything about those block
sections it's just it has to be that way
that's just kind of how the layout works
to be fair the fact that I added a block
section at the end of what is
essentially a kiddie coaster is already
kind of setting this thing apart so I
think it's fine but yeah oh no it's a
very simple short sweet scenario I
really like how this sort of outcrop
with the jr. coaster worked out with the
lighthouse especially because I just
really wanted to add some variety to my
lighthouse architecture I've built so
many red white black lighthouses in this
game the
I figured it would be nice to try my
hand at something else and I'm keeping
everything very simple it's not too
detailed but I do like the combination
of the different colors and materials
and stuff and then the top over here is
just kind of a Miss mishmash of like
different kinds of Beach Boulevard
architecture which is still kind of
strange because technically it looks
like a Beach Boulevard but then the
actual beach is down here it's like they
just raised an entire Bulevar up
including some of the the bars that
you'd normally find at a beach because I
feel like especially the building on top
of the scrambled eggs here kind of has
that beach bar arc is a cure except on
like stilts basically but yeah all
things considered I'm pretty happy with
this scenario and the fact that I
managed to somehow at least bridge the
the lower section of the park with the
higher section up here so yeah let's not
say too many words about it anymore I'm
just gonna save the park here and let's
move on to the main menu and see
actually what the final little building
is that we get put on the map honestly
I'm not really sure but I guess it's
yeah it's just the entrance building
that makes sense all right so that's it
for sure cliffs and that means that we
get the final island which is going to
be over here the Haunted Island which is
where the very last scenario of the game
is located but I have to say before I
move on to that I really have to do Robo
Park so next episode is going to be all
about Robo Park hope you guys enjoyed
this video and I hope to see you in the
next video let's get going